[Music]
so what was it like when you got the gig
of a lifetime really and you got the
call you're gonna be Britney's love
interest Lydia so actually that wasn't
my first music video
that was my second first on was work
from home from fifth harmony okay so it
was fun you know I got a lot of
attention from fifth harmony so I knew
what I was stepping into I said fifth
harmony was just coming out as a as a
little group and now Britney Spears the
Princess of Pop is calling me wanting me
to be the play the love interest of the
movie I said why not let me give it a
shot
and so did you have to audition like how
does that work for videos I did not have
to audition the direct book honey
it was a direct book a good friend of
mine was working on the music video at
the time okay they told the casting
director he should cast this guy yeah
and then they send my pictures to fit my
girlfriend and she picked it she said I
wanted this guy and then so that's
that's how it was and so what a trip
because then five months later you get
another call and it's not to be in the
video it's let's go eat some sushi right
absolutely what does your mind just
explode you it's real life I mean at the
music video we connected we talked like
you know she said before we talked on
the music video we talked about what
what do you like to eat sushi here and
there and then you know text messages
and next thing you know a date just like
a normal couple